[Musique]
et donc nous allons parler d'eux de quoi
non vous savez pas lire enfin ce n'est
pas un thé c'est en elle
vous confondez les lettres ce n'est pas
un g c'est un v go veut vous confondez
les sons mais enfin vous n'avez jamais
appris à lire
vous venez de faire l'expérience de la
dyslexie
ce trouble qui rend l'apprentissage de
la lecture difficile mais c'est bien de
livres dont je veux parler ce soir c'est
bien de livres parce que c'est dans les
livres qu'on trouve la connaissance
c'est par les cris qu'on accède à la
connaissance et que se passe-t-il quand
on ne peut pas accéder à l'écrit on ne
peut pas accéder à la connaissance
c'est le cas des 10 apprendre à lire
apprendre à lire c'est l'apprentissage
le plus difficile qui soit et pourtant
vous avez tous appris à lire alors vous
me croyez pas et pourtant je vais vous
convaincre il ya un scientifique
français qui s'appelle stanislas des
haines et qui parle de recyclage
neuronale notre cerveau a une capacité
formidable
il est capable de reconnaître les formes
et ça depuis le plus jeune âge le bébert
connaît très très bien le visage de sa
maman nous reconnaissons des visages
dans les nuages dans les desseins de la
roche
cette capacité d'ailleurs ça nous fait
peur quand on ne voit pas le visage des
gens quand on a une cagoule sur le gign
ou un voile intégral dans certaines
religions extrême ou encore quand on a
le masque des anonymous
ça nous fait peur parce qu'on voit pas
le visage
c'est une propriété de l'être humain que
de reconnaître les visages et c'est une
propriété très très très efficace si je
vous dis ce visage c'est marion ce
visage là c'est aussi marion notre
cerveau est parfaitement capable de
gérer la symétrie alors expliquez-moi
pourquoi cette lettre c'est un p mais
pas celle-là est celle là oui par contre
vous voyez comme c'est difficile
d'apprendre à lire et ça c'est quand on
a un cerveau qui fonctionne mais
certains cerveaux 10 fonctionne ce gros
mot pour parler des 10 des dyslexiques
des dyspraxiques des dysphasiques des
dix orthographique des dyscalculiques
tout un tas de troubles qu'on appelle la
galaxie des 10 je m'appelle marion
berthaud et j'ai créé il ya quatre ans
une start-up numérique
justement pour aider à trouver des
solutions pour aider les enfants disent
à lire alors dans mes travaux j'ai
cherché comme tout le monde des
solutions pour remédier pour corriger le
handicap pour entraîner la compétence
déficiente pour faire faire des lignes
d'écriture ad10 graphique ça marche pas
et puis j'ai rencontré des gens sur mon
parcours et en particulier quelqu'un qui
avait une approche différente c'est le
professeur pascal collet qui l'état
préfère l'institut commission
dans le sud de la france et elle l avait
une démarche différente qui consistait
non pas à essayer d'entraîner ce qui
était déficient mais plutôt d'essayer de
trouver ce qui marchait bien
si la jambe droite fonctionne pas bien
pourquoi pas s'appuyer sur la jambe
gauche et donc elle a été regardé chez
les dyslexiques qui avait réussi à
compenser leur dyslexiques comment il
avait fait elle a pris des 10 qui
faisait des études
donc on peut penser que ben il avait
réussi à malgré leur dyslexie ham a
passé outre et elle les a mis dans une
irm pour regarder leur cerveau donc
savait par irm on peut voir les
différentes zones du cerveau qui sont
activés au au fur et à mesure que vous
faites une action au fur et à mesure que
vous lisez par exemple sans grande
surprise la sphère du décodage celle qui
permet de décoder les lettres le paie
par exemple elle était moins rapide que
celle des normes aux lecteurs en même
temps c'était des 10 pas vraiment un
scoop
en revanche elle a découvert que la
serre qui s'occupe de la sémantique
c'est à dire du sens elle elle marchait
très bien et voire même elle marchait
mieux c'est un peu comme si le cerveau
se sachant déficient d'un côté compensé
par un autre côté un peu comme ces
aveugles qui ont une ouïe très fine
cette sphère sémantique et est donc un
moyen de pouvoir utiliser la jambe
gauche puisque l'agent devra ne marchait
pas bien le décodage alors plus
concrètement ça veut dire quoi la sphère
sémantique si je vous demande des pelé
le mot bicyclette
allez-y non velo101 avait compris
l'espère sémantique
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cette
découverte là et bien il se trouve que
pour aider les dyslexiques qui ont des
problèmes de segmentation segmenter les
lettres dans les mots on utilise une
coloration des syllabes
par exemple si je vous dis le mot
chatons on va dire chat saoirse ton t om
chatons ça c'est un moyen de dd la
segmentation du mou en syllabes et bien
parce qu'elle que lesdits et si au lieu
d'utiliser le découpage syllabique on
utilisait le morphèmes alors le
morphèmes c'est ce qui constitue le sens
du mot chat ch a t on le petit du comme
dans our sont comme dans canetons non
pas comme dans hérisson et donc la
découpe agents morphèmes allez pouvoir
aider les dyslexiques à reconnaître le
sens du mot est donc à pouvoir compenser
leur dyslexie utiliser leur jambe gauche
puisque la jambe droite marche pas bien
alors c'est pas si simple que ça a
appliqué de mon côté puisque il falloir
maintenant qu'on trouve des moteurs
linguistique pour être capable de
détecter les morphèmes à l'intérieur des
mots pour pouvoir le faire en
automatique
on en a pour quelques années de
recherche encore mais voilà des pistes
intéressantes
voilà ce qui m'a intéressé moi dans mon
travail de travailler plutôt sur la
jambe gauche
quand la jambe droite marche pas alors
vous allez me dire oui mais la jambe
droite
la mienne ça va et fonctionne bien je
m'en sers en ce moment pour dire bonjour
parce que j'ai pas le droit de faire des
poignées de mains à cause du courant
d'un virus mais c'est pas forcément le
cas de tout le monde et surtout sera pas
forcément votre cas toute votre vie
il ya des gens qui ont des accidents il
ya des gens qui en vieillissant perdre
des fonctions ça reste intéressant de
chercher sa jambe gauche mais le plus la
plus grande raison pour laquelle ça
reste intéressant c'est parce que dans
cette jambe gauche il y à des trésors
des trésors insoupçonnés une mine d'or
il ya des super pouvoirs je vais revenir
aux 10 puisque c'est ça mon métier et je
vais vous citer c'est ma collègue sophie
qui doit être dans la salle d'ailleurs
qui m'expliquait cette image qui est
utilisé par steve masson qui est un euro
pédagogue québécois et qui dit
représenter vous le cerveau comme une
forêt vous devez traverser cette forêt
alors passer à côté d'un arbuste à côté
d'un arbre puis fur et à mesure que vous
prenez toujours le même endroit il ya
comme un petit sentier qui se crée qui
ce sentier à force de passer il
s'élargit
il vient chemin et puis une route et
puis une autoroute
le problème des dix c'est que la
végétation est tellement vivent
tellement forte que le petit chemin et
ben il est envahi par la végétation et
envers y ait envahi et au final ce petit
sentier devient jamais une route et
devient jamais une autoroute et pourtant
il ya un trésor là et ce trésor c'est
que pendant que vous êtes en train de
chercher votre chemin vous êtes capable
de voir ce petit chemin là sur le côté
que vous n'aviez pas vu avant et qui est
un raccourci vous vous le voyez mais
ceux qui vont à toute allure il voit pas
il ya un trésor dans cette jambe gauche
la dyslexie
selon le msc 5% de la population
j'ai pas combien on est dans la salle
aujourd'hui 300 il ya 15 pour ce 15
personnes ici qui sont concernés alors
je vous félicite parce que vous vous
avez cette capacité à voir ce petit
moi je file à cent à l'heure sur mon
autoroutes et je le vois pas cette
capacité de sortir des sentiers battus
c'est la créativité
ça a été d'ailleurs prouvé par une
scientifique une neuroscientifique
polonaise qui s'appelle martha loppsi
est vite et qui a montré que non
seulement les dix avaient plus de
créativité
statistiquement que les normes aux
lecteurs mais qu'en plus quand on
entraînait cette créativité c'était plus
efficace l'entraînement par l'art
thérapie par un tout un tas de formation
était plus efficace chez les 10 ils ont
bénéficié d' avantages et tous les jours
on a on a des cas concrets dans les
personnes créatives les artistes steven
spielberg et 10 agatha christie étaient
10 mais on a aussi des scientifiques
dès lors le plus célèbre léonard de
vinci ou albert einstein des politiques
wiston churchill
on a des mastodontes de numérique
steve jobs elon musk on a plein de gens
qui sont dit c'est qui le revendique
aux etats unis quand vous avez un
recruteur qui cherche quelqu'un pour un
poste qui demande de la créativité
il privilégie les dix en france quand on
publie une annonce on explique le poste
est ouvert aussi aux porteurs de
handicap
et vous combien d'entre vous ont mis à
l'écart un cv simplement parce qu'il
était bourré de fautes
alors la prochaine fois que ça vous
arrive à les récupérer le cv dans la
poubelle et donnez lui une deuxième
chance et peut-être que ce jour-là
indices vous dira merki
là il ya des trésors dans les gens de
gauche mois les trésors que je vais
chercher c'est dans les jambes gauche
des gens qui n'arrivent pas à lire des
gens qui par ce biais là n'ont pas accès
à la connaissance parce que leur cerveau
soit disant dysfonctionne eh bien ces
dysfonctionnements c'est des mines d'or
il y a des trésors dans votre jambe
gauche il y a des trésors dans la jambe
gauche de votre voisin alors en sortant
de cette salle ce que je vous propose
c'est de lui demander à votre voisin
et vous c'est quoi votre jambe gauche et
là moi je vous dirais n'est requis
[Applaudissements]